die leute herzlich willkommen zu diesem
neuen video ich habe ein paar tagen wenn
sie ganz toll gemacht in die zukunft
machen wir fragen zu stellen
ich wollte dieses video draußen drehen
weil die sonne gerade gescheitert sagte
jo ist schön sondern mal so im herbst
aber es regnet deswegen sind wir uns
gleich wieder im hof so da sind wir auch
schon ich bin jetzt auf reges platz weil
der heute nicht alt und deswegen dachte
ich mir ich beanspruche den jetzt aber
mal nicht die erste frage kommen von
dschihad paddle warst du gut in der
schule
ich war nie besonders gut in der schule
lag aber auch daran weil ich nie
besonders viel gelernt habe und in der
elften und zwölften klasse kann ich
einfach glück reden dass ich immer
irgendwie noch durchgekommen bin ohne zu
lernen die nächste frage kommt von
mister dn 13
findest du es in köln schöner als in
bayern kann man nicht wirklich sagen
allerdings bin ich einfach keinen kohl
wegen der leute ich bin cool weißt du
positiv in köln cool weil es einfach ein
großer ist und natürlich verbinden
können auch damit was mir jetzt gerade
im moment alles ermöglicht wird deswegen
ja ich bin schon ziemlich geil aber
schöner würde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt
sagen mad max 158 fragt magst du
nintendo endpunkt lewandowski 19 fragt
wie alt bist du und kannst du mich
grüßen also erstmal größe gehen raus an
endpunkt lewandowski 19
und ich bin 19 also ich hab jetzt
gefragt zwar nicht kreativ aber sein
lieblingstier und wie ist das eigentlich
für remy zu arbeiten der zweiten frage
wie es ist für baby zu arbeiten komme
ich später noch mal ein lieblingstier
dürfte eigentlich hatte sein ich bin
allerdings auch so was wie ihnen malen
oder irgendwelche anderen exotischen
tiere eigentlich ziemlich geil und auch
ziemlich interessant einige 3000 frage
ist eher wie ein schlimmer fall sei es
extrem schwer wenn man das so liest
region schlimmer chef einfach nur wegen
des geschäfts klar er ist mein schatz
ich arbeite für ihn logisch aber
irgendwie kommen zu einem halt nicht
sofort meine rede ganz normal wenn man
ganz normale jobs mann warf sich
gegenseitig das ist eigentlich echt
ziemlich entspannt und drewes kein
schlimmer chili punkte sie fragt sind
reli und schott die wirklich zusammen oh
ja da müsst ihr sie am besten selbst
fragen wenn er hat geschrieben wie sieht
das aus wenn du eine regel wieder
schneide ist hier mal kurz einen blick
[Musik]
wenn du bist gefragt oder trägt lea
hallo freddy sagt man die wendung fragt
oder re bindung frägt fragt du vollidiot
danke ja wenn du krank bist du stolz die
skater zu sein ja tatsächlich also es
bewerben sich wahrscheinlich jeden tag
in die zehn leute oder so die wahl wie
schneiden wollen und dann derjenige zu
sein der davon leben kann dies zu
schneiden ist schon ziemlich cool ja
doch der oder re liebe youtube und so
zeug fragt ist das anstrengend mit
reviers comics frage warum hast du mich
noch nie einen streich gespielt bitte
forschung ja da überlege ich mir
definitives du hast einen gang charakter
und danke dass du bei regen jedoch nicht
gekündigt ist erstmal danke und naja da
wird nicht so schnell auch nicht los ich
liebe meinen job rede mir fragt wieso
läufst du so oft beiträge hatte bieter
im rennen die bruder machst du das ich
lag auf beiträge von diesem fanseiten
und deswegen gehe ich wenn ich irgendwo
markiert werde auch bei dem profil dann
durch und leicht einfach alle bilder
einfach nur um zu zeigen hey ich bin
cool was ihr macht die johanna fragt
woher hast du deinen computer
fähigkeiten wie alt ich bin immer noch
19 und ich hab meinen tollen computer
fähigkeiten mir selbst beigebracht genug
eine spezielle schule gegangen hab auf
dem studiert habe auch nicht vor
ich habe mir das alles beigebracht und
darauf bin ich tatsächlich auch dessen
stadt lucca gefragt was für einen beruf
oder so früher haben also ganz früher
als ich so sieben oder acht jahre alt
war wollte ich immer so wie man korrekt
maler werden also quasi diese hofmann
wenn durch reicht somit 16 wollte ich
dann filme und musikvideos machen hab
dann aber irgendwann realisiert hätte
ich kann auch komplett crazy sein und
wirklich meinen wirklichen traum
erfüllen und eben wir youtube arbeiten
und das hat sich jetzt so krass wie es
klingt tierfotografie fragt was denkst
du dir haufen nehmen es ist echt mega
witzig wie krass die teilweise lacht und
ab geht und man denkt uns ein videos
ermöglicht dass es fähig ist aber ist es
echt nicht er lacht einfach wirklich
genau so und ich denke nein
wie kann man nur so vor rückzahlen
wieder für diesen klub sie denn fragt
wie hast du revier und generell alle aus
dem buch kennen gelernt alle anderen aus
dem buch habe ich durch liebe
kennengelernt und wir können gern habe
darauf werde ich noch mal am ende des
videos zu sprechen kommen michael punkt
wären fragt wie ist es einen verrückten
zu betrachten
mein lieblings kommentar ex annika exakt
hast du hunger ja alle welchen da nehme
ich so was von mir jetzt videos lexus
fragen wie lange schon gitarre und
welche schauen das bist du am liebsten
angefangen hab ich tatsächlich schon mit
11 oder mit zehn da haben wir so ein
kumpel smog und der worte auf gitarre
beigebracht was richtig leicht ist aber
da habe ich schon so ein bisschen die
liebe zur gitarre festgestellt und da
meine mutter auch rita gespielt hat und
wir deswegen 23 getan zuhause rumliegen
hatten habe ich einfach mal angefangen
zwar nicht sehr intensiv gespielt aber
immer mal wieder und deswegen kann ich
es mittlerweile auch einigermaßen 20 mal
ganz kurz erklären wieso dass die
frächter ist das scheiße ist bruder
jahren meine haare nicht gemacht oder
bei der welt verlieren haben sie mal
ganz kurz den leuten erkennen wieso dass
die audioqualität plötzlich ganz scheiße
ist wenn ich mein mikro wieder zurück du
bist könnte es packt ball gewann ist ein
ausschnitt von apple nämlich so was man
jetzt video so meinen kurz grad lag
gegangen machten wir weiter jan-philipp
fotografie fragt was ist dein
lieblingsessen und das ist natürlich
eine sehr sehr schwierige frage ich es
nämlich so ziemlich alles mir schmeckt
auch so ziemlich alles mein
lieblingsessen ist glaube ich
tatsächlich wenn der papa oder malen die
rindsrouladen kocht aber ansonsten heißt
ich sehr gerne exotisches essen alles
möglich auch gerne leicht zu sagen aber
mein leben bleibt trotzdem die
rindsroulade lisa und lena vor was ist
das fragt hey du bist doch mit video
oder so ja ich bin mit rewe genau
passiert fragt was würdest du gerne
einmal erleben
fallschirmspringen weil ich auf jeden
fall erleben ich will waren die champion
ich würde auch gerne mal parabelflüge
erleben dass das halten und quasi mit
einem flugzeug nach oben dann gehen die
motoren aus und dann fällt man so runter
mit dem flugzeug und innerhalb des
flugzeugs kommt einem so vor als wäre
man in der schwerelosigkeit die
vorletzte frage kommt von unterstrich
unterstrich unterstrich gut verfolgt den
typen erstmal rein auf den scrum ich
habe den in der beschreibung verlinken
übrigen auf jeden fall die frage lautet
welches ist ein lieblingslied und was
bedeutet dass ihr aktuell ist mein
lieblingslied und sterblichkeit pro aber
so eins meiner oldtimer lieblingslieder
über den ich auch weiß dass sie
die in zwei jahren auch überall finden
werde is ongoing von crucell und zwar
geht es in diesem jahr wird der quasi
die leidenschaft seiner musik beschreibt
und wir halt immer weitermacht und nicht
aufgibt und dadurch weil sich seine
ziele erreicht und dieses lied hat mich
ziemlich krass motiviert so in der phase
in der ich bei meinen eltern allein zu
hause in meinem zimmer eingesperrt war
und quasi nur nächtelang durch glaubt
deshalb an gewissen sehr sehr extrem
aufwendigen projekten auf jeden fall
mich dieses liedern war motiviert
weiterzumachen nicht aufzugeben
nächtelang durchzuarbeiten und deswegen
verbinde ich damit sehr viel positives
die letzte frage wurde ganz oft gestellt
stellvertretend nehme ich jetzt einfach
mal das beispiel von de mello
unterstrich es unterstrich
wie bist du so revier gekommen und was
hast du vorher gemacht also vorher habe
ich an musik wie das gearbeitet habe
versucht musiker kennen zu lernen für
dich musikvideos machen kann irgendwann
sieht immer bekanntere auftraggeber zu
haben um quasi irgendwann davon leben zu
können
dazu würde ich wahrscheinlich noch mal
ein ganzes video widmen da ich denke das
ist viele von euch interessieren könnte
und ich da jetzt keine details aus
sparen möchte und jetzt die frage wie
bis zur ewige kommen also ich habe mich
im sommer 2016 bei einem sehr bekannten
youtube beworben hat tatsächlich eine
antwort bekommen und wurde auch dorthin
eingeladen was erstmal wieder krasses
hat allerdings nicht geklappt was mich
zu dieser zeit sehr sehr traurig gemacht
hat aber was ich dadurch gelernt habe
ist dass youtuber auch nur menschen sind
und auch auf ihre e mails tatsächlich
antworten wenn man nicht mehr dann raus
findet also welchen grund hat ein paar
youtube geschrieben die ich kult band
habe dann auch einige antworten bekommen
habe mich mit welchen getroffen habt
sogar bevor ich bei rewe gearbeitet habe
schon mal bei einem anderen youtuber
gearbeitet das ist aber eine andere
story auf jeden fall habe ich damit
revier geredet wir haben uns ziemlich
gut verstanden er fand ziemlich cool was
ich so drauf hat ja eine probeweise
einige videos geschickt ich habe dir
angeschnitten musste natürlich jedes
video ungefähr zehn stunden downloaden
und auch wünschen ablaufen kann mein
internet zu hause in dem dorf so
schlecht war ja am anfang gab es noch
einige probleme ich glaube das erste
video welches ich für rhede geschnitten
habe hatte dann noch mal komplett selbst
gemacht und
fand auch cool dass sich dieses visual
effects zeug drauf habe für irgendwelche
anderen projekte wie jetzt zum beispiel
dieses musikvideo welches in der planung
ist und deswegen hat er mich schon
gefragt ob ich denn mal nach köln ziehen
möchte was ich natürlich schon immer
wollte aber ich war dann auch in berlin
aus gründen die ich irgendwann noch mal
genauer erklären möchte auf jeden fall
als ich dann irgendwann so ergeben dass
ich nach köln ziehen konnte und jetzt
bin ich hier und ja auch der rest ist
geschichte wir in unserer schönen sagen
auf jeden fall danke fürs zu sehen hier
übrigens vor
die konstellation wie ich wenn ich diese
kamera halte mein arm ist schon so
schwer ich habe jetzt auf jeden fall
circa 40 minuten aufgenommen werde das
aber alles zusammen schneiden ist dauert
erst mal eine weile bis ich mich damit
anfreunden mit der kamera zu reden als
es immer noch total komisch für mich
irgendwie das was von diesem video ich
würde mich freuen wenn ihr den kanal
abonnieren würde wenn der daumen da
lass' mir beim nächsten wieder dabei
seid das war mir bis dahin
[Musik]